so hopefully everybody's got the
notebook in front of them and has
Seaborn either was installed or or we're
able to install it so obviously I'm
going to talk about visualization today
using Python but a lot of what I'm going
to focus on is just general data
exploration and what we call exploratory
data analysis and a little more about me
the data set is in that git repo it's an
old one as you can probably tell when
you look at the auto the prices of cars
being a few thousand dollars on average
or something like that but it's from
1985 but that doesn't that isn't that
important what we're really interested
in here is how do we take you know a
reasonably complex data set that has a
lot of different columns of different
types and visually understand it and
also tools that you can use to then
present observations you might have from
from visual analysis to your colleagues
and bosses and customers whatever so so
this whole idea of visualization
exploratory data analysis in the history
of analytics and statistics and what is
relatively new John Tukey who I was
privileged to know as a graduate student
at Princeton published this book in 1977
and this was sort of the culmination of
research he had done for about almost 20
years before that and before that graph
you know statisticians and other types
analysts there were no data scientists
obviously in 1977 that's a fairly new
term you know would put a graph or two
into something into a report or into a
paper but it was mostly about tables and
it was very theoretical and Tookie
stepped back and said wait there's a lot
you can learn just by
visually examining your data really
trying to understand the relationships
in your data and you know using a
combination of maybe simple summary
statistics and in graphical methods and
that was a big revelation believe it or
not I mean nowadays I think it's it
seems so obvious but maybe it wasn't in
1977 another influence on me at least
but also on the whole field was this
work by built by Bill Cleveland who was
then director of the stats math group at
ATT Bell Labs someone else I had the
privilege to work with when I was at a
company called statistical sciences
where we commercialized Bell Labs s
which you know eventually became
open-source R and so bill very
systematically went about trying to find
different you know he basically tested a
lot of different ideas about graphics
and how you can subdivide and present
data and how people perceive it and he
tested that a lot of times on not just
an average person on the street you know
sample but on fellow scientists at Bell
Labs so it was amazing how many times
they didn't understand the plots that
other people were showing them even
those very sophisticated aliens I don't
do a lot with this here but I just want
you guys to be aware of obviously Edward
Tufte and Yale professor still for a
long time this was his original sort of
seminal book in the early 90s also and
again he he looked at a different aspect
of this than where Cleveland and Tukey
came from and he was more interested in
the clarity of the presentation and so
he has if you look at that book you'll
see there's some interesting rules about
you know what's the ratio of actual
information to the amount of ink you're
well in those days ink because it was
all on you know mechanical
plotters in those days but screen pixels
I think nowadays I guess so
so our goals are just what I've outlined
here to explore complex data using
visualization look at different chart
types you can use because when you're
exploring complex data there's not just
one chart type you know you don't just
keep doing the same thing over try a lot
of different things expect to fail a lot
and keep trying different things and
then we hit this problem immediately
which is a lot of what Cleveland
especially was working on is no matter
how you represent computer-generated
graphics it's on a 2d surface regardless
of whether it's printed on paper or
nowadays we project it on to a computer
screen
it's basically flat right it's 2d and
you know maybe you could do something
fancy with VR headsets or something and
get a third dimension but complex data
has many more dimensions than that and
so a couple of ways around that we'll
use what we call plot aesthetics which
I'll get on to and also a method which
has been reinvented by many people and
I'll talk about that conditioning or
faceting where you you basically do
different group bys of the data it's
like a group by operation so there's
some resources here I put in the
notebook you know in two hours we're
just going to like scratch the surface
if even so just on how to do stuff
there's a lot of useful information like
matplotlib which is as I'll show you
it's kind of the base package for almost
all Python graphics there there are a
few exceptions like bouquet which we
don't have time to go into that do other
types of you know plotting base packages
but if you go to this website that I
gave you on its matplotlib org
/resources /h index there's just a lot
of stuff from tutorials and videos and
it's it's a books and and what and this
is pretty highly curated this isn't just
like some random list this is pretty
high quality material some of you may
have been with us in the last session in
this room for the pandas tutorial and
there's pandas Paideia org slash panda
slash types anyway you can see it
there's this tutorial on visualization
which goes through a lot of the basics
of how to if you have your data in a
panda's data frame just a lot of stuff
you can do with very few lines of code
I'd say that's the main advantage of
this you can get sometimes a long ways
with not doing a lot of code and then a
relatively new package that we're going
to take advantage of here is Seaborn and
which is the one I wanted to make sure
everybody had installed it is take the
people who are doing C boarded I think
this is still a sort of an in-flight
project that there's missing pieces and
things that when I work with it I feel
like gee it really there should be
something here so I hope they're
continued to do new releases of this
they seem to be active there seem to be
some active contributions going on it
takes a lot of more sophisticated
plotting ideas a lot of them from the
our world a lot of this stuff that that
was done earlier on tended to be in our
and so are plotting was generally a
little bit ahead of Python world and so
they've tried with with this package PI
a seaborne but also another package
called ggplot which tries to imitate the
ggplot2 package
that's revolutionized graphics and our
but we're not going to you know I can
only do so much in two hours so we're
going to just focus on Seabourn which is
enough so we're going to do three
different kinds of plotting but but
don't get discouraged because the base
plotting is always matplotlib for all
these in and it's for the ggplot package
as well so by the way if you have
questions please interrupt and raise
your hand also I think on the live feed
we have somebody monitoring the Twitter
if you're online watching and you'd like
to come up with a question please do and
we got a microphone we can pass around
for the questions so so the first thing
is we got to just load this data and how
many of you are somewhat at least
somewhat comfortable with pandas I hope
or have been in the pandas tutorial just
now okay so it's a majority by far so so
I'm going to load this data into pandas
dataframe I don't want to spend a lot of
time on pandas because we just had a
pandas tutorial that some of you may
have been in but so the basics are you
know Pete you know so I import pandas as
PD so PD that reads the CSV the file
name and I've assigned file name and
then I'm going to give the cup there are
certain columns that are that have
missing values and so and they happen to
be in these columns these so that's a
list of my column names and so and in
this data set they don't use an NA or a
Miss or a null or something like that
they use a text question mark as the
missing value that's just how it was
coded so so first I can I convert all
those to a numpy nan so basically a
missing value and then I drop
I drop them you know if there and I
convert those also to numeric because
they show up because of the missing
values being coded as a text or a string
question mark they show up with string
columns whereas they're really numeric
so we'll run that whole thing and with
any luck it's going to work
you guys can run it on your local
environments - all right so whenever
you're exploring data you should get
some idea of what like what's in the
data right don't don't just start
randomly doing stuff so let's just look
at the head of that data frame with the
head method so got head is the head
method I could say N equals something
here you know like N equals 10 or
something but oops but for obvious
reasons I'm not going to do there no
idea what that happened so let me just
run that and you've got and so what we
see is just the first five rows got some
columns we're not going to use I think
the original idea this data set
originally was put together having to do
with insurance losses on different types
of automobiles but we're going to focus
on their price a little easier to
understand so so you have the make you
know who made it what type of fuel does
it use aspiration aspiration means like
how does the air get into the engine
like as a turbo or standard number of
doors body style drive wheels you'll see
what how this works as we go etc and
then some things about some features
about the engine and finally the price
of the car
let me just fix that okay and we can if
we just use the describe method that'll
give us again some summary statistics on
those columns and let's just look at a
couple of these here like lengths okay
so we can see there's 195 cars in the
that where we have a length value the
mean length I think these are in inches
is 174 the standard deviation isn't
actually that much considering and and
the range is actually from minimum of a
hundred and forty one to a maximum of
208 so like is this an idea that cars
don't have you know they're not super
short they're not extremely long they're
in a fairly narrow range and you can
look at these quantiles you know the 25
percent the 50 percent which is the same
as the median which is pretty close to
the mean so that also tells us that
distribution of lengths of cars is
probably fairly symmetric right whereas
if we scroll over here to price we'll
see the mean price is $13,000 which like
I said this is kind of an old data set
and and we've got the standard deviation
is quite wide actually 8,000 so we've
got a big range of price in fact prices
go from five thousand dollars to forty
five thousand dollars and and the median
is ten thousand dollars whereas the mean
is thirteen thousand dollars so so in
terms of exploring this data we know
that price is highly skewed so so those
are just some things there's other
things you can look at here but those
are just some things we'll keep in mind
as we think about what charts
what visualizations are useful to to
digging into this data set so so let's
so now I'd like to just go through some
basic plot types
and and introduce you to how we make
those plots which is you know one of our
objectives here so that you come away
with a working knowledge of Python
plotting and how you use it to explore
data and also how you can use it to
create presentation graphics so a really
basic plot that everybody works with of
course is the scatter plot and let's
just do the first one in math plot libe
and the recipe I'm showing you here is
really simple so obviously we have to
import matplotlib dot pie plot because
we're doing it from Python right and
we're going to use the plot method and
we can just say what values of x and y
we want and I want dot red dots okay to
worry for each data point okay so the
type has to be R for red and an O small
oh for an O or a dot okay and notice
there's one thing since we're working in
a in Jupiter notebook and it runs an eye
Python interpreter if you don't include
this magic command matplotlib in line
with the % in front it will not plot
your graph in line I mean you would
normally think that would be what should
happen right you run a plot command
you'd want to see the plot in the
ipython you know whether you're running
in a night Python shell or an O in a
Jupiter notebook that runs ipython but
that's not the default you have to say
so so you can see what so just to show
you in code plot you know so I've
imported matplotlib pipe lot as plot PLT
so I've got PLT dot plot and then I've
got X Y and type so it's pretty simple
right so go ahead and run that
and we got a plot but and so we have
price on the vertical axis presumably
and city miles per gallon so some
measure of fuel efficiency of those cars
on the horizontal axis consider can
people see there's a couple of obvious
deficiencies of just taking this kind of
default Matt plot live plot can what are
a couple of them that you guys see
anybody yeah you know and label the axis
that's a big annoyance yeah anything
else you guys see yeah huh yeah there's
over plotting that's a good one we'll
get to working on that but there's
another one anybody else see it
yes yeah the x-axis is chopping actually
the y axis is just scaled to the max and
min so the dots are chopped down here on
the bottom and and that's just because
we took the defaults we didn't try to do
anything fancy by the way this business
of not labeling axes is is a huge when I
you know I I think was mentioned in my
introduction I teach data science
classes for both UW and for Harvard and
it's a huge pet peeve of mine because
you get something like this and you
don't know whether you know it's average
shoe size versus cows born or what you
know what's this plot you have no idea
right it could be anything and and to
keep that in mind so let's do a little
better so I have this in a panda's data
frame as you saw right that's how we
loaded it and so I can take that data
frame Auto dot prices and apply the
pandas plot method and I'll say the kind
is a scatter plot so kind equals scatter
in quotes and then I just say X what my
x and y are just like I did before and
go ahead and run that and you see you
get a somewhat new and improved plot
right
it's got axes labels the these circles
aren't chopped off you still can't tell
how many points are over plotting here
very well we'll get to that but but at
least for one line of code we've got a
sort of more miles for her better better
output for just the one line of code
using the pandas plot method that's
because pandas plot method is built as
an abstraction layer over the mat plot
line and you get more so I want you guys
to go ahead and try this yourself I'm
going to give you a couple minutes to do
this so do Auto price versus curb weight
and there's
somewhere up here if you look at the
column names there's one called curb
weight which is C which is as you can
imagine sort of the weight of the car
when it's empty okay so just give that a
try
[Music]
oh and to execute the code and if you
don't know in a Jupiter notebook cell
just hit shift enter with the with the
cursor anywhere in that cell and it'll
execute the code actually how many of
you have never used a Jupiter notebook
before only like two okay so hopefully
it's not too overwhelming
[Music]
oh there's a question way in the back
could you run the microphone back there
logging is oh oh yeah I can so I can't
hear you it's on hello yes so fun y-axis
your y-axis starts with zero for me
starting at 5000 hmm that could just be
different versions of pandas plotting
I'm not as you can see you can force X
limits and Y limits as attributes which
we'll look at a little bit about
attributes right now I'm not controlling
them so it's probably just a different
version okay was there another question
way in the back - nope all right okay
well hopefully you guys got something
that looks about like this it may not be
as we just discussed exactly this but
okay so let's get a little more
sophisticated here this is a really
simple recipe right we're just using one
line of code we can specify an X Y a
kind and you know we'll get some you can
get some mileage out of that so to speak
but let's use some of the math plot live
capabilities so so I'm going to define a
figure which I'm going to call fig and
it's plot dot figure and I can you can
if you look at the dock for this there's
all sorts of attributes about gridlines
and all sorts of stuff right now I'm
just going to say fig size equals six by
six so it's going to be sick in at least
the way I've got my notebook set up it
will be six by six inches and then now
that I've defined that figure I can say
get a let's set up I'm just going to do
one axis on it so GC a is a method
it defines an axis and so now I've got
you know Auto underbar prices got plot
so this is all the same as you just saw
before except now I say what's the axis
so I say ax equals ax here right so now
I'm now I've said okay don't just use
any default axis use the axis I'm
telling you to use and okay so now that
I've defined what axis it is I can set
all sorts of attributes including as we
just talked about excellent limits and Y
limits and plotting but I'm just going
to say ax dot set title so I give it a
title set X label so I give it an x axis
label I give it a y axis label and you
see it doesn't look a whole lot
different than the plot I had before but
I do have my title here I do have sort
of more human readable axis labels so is
that clear how I did that to everybody
because that's kind of an important it's
simple but it's also important if you
what we're going to do sure
oh so the question is why are we setting
all those attributes after the plot I
think the answer is it doesn't really
matter I suppose you could set them
before the plot it's just the kit but
because you're just setting up different
attributes of how the plots going to be
displayed and you're saying use this
access to the pandas method so I don't
know you could trick I don't know let's
try it let's see what if we turn it
around I think it won't matter yeah okay
you tried it and it doesn't matter no it
doesn't matter because it's just it's
just going to run through all that and
you've only set one figure so anything
that applies to that axis it'll just
keep you know it's like a compound
operation it's going to plot them and I
suppose the order they're listed in the
code but the end result isn't going to
look any different
okay so here's another hi can you
explain the difference between figure
and axis like can you switch the order
of those in the code the order of I'm
sorry the order of which big equals plot
figure and axe equals fig GCA what's
what is the difference well I had to
know I have to define a figure first
which is just a plot area the figure
that I'm defining when I set that figure
size is just a plot area you'll see
later we'll have multiple axes on a
figure so yes I have to create a figure
before I can say that it gets one or
more axes what if you create another
figure after that well then you're
starting another figure it'll be
everything I'm plotting here if I define
a new if I run another figure method
I'll be working on a new figure
was there another question behind there
no okay yeah hopefully you'll see that
because well we'll get to making
multiple axes on a plot I hope I hope
hope I have time this okay so a little
exercise
so take your plot that you did before
which is recall was the plot of the
price versus curb weight and try to
decorate it with a title and some axes
labels and what and also where you can
control the figure sighs you don't have
to do 6x6 and you can do your own if you
want to see 4x4 or 8x8 whatever whatever
you know it doesn't even have to be
rectangular to tell you the truth I mean
you could do by
[Music]
timeline
did everybody kind of get that then and
you can also cheat and see what I did I
changed mine up a little bit I said oh
I'm going to make mine wider so I made
it eight by six so I've got a slightly
different aspect ratio than then the
wreck square we have before for no good
reason at this point just doing it to do
it
okay everybody with us oh here's a
question the style will mean the shapes
and the colors those are aesthetics
we'll get to aesthetics so the question
was how do you set the types of points
but we'll talk about aesthetics once
we've gone through the basic block types
so another plot type is a line plot Oh
the units at least the way I have my
notebook set up it's it's it's inches
but it's inches based on some scale it
never quite comes out in real inches on
my screen so it's a little inches in
some buddy scale but it's a little hard
to know usually if I'm trying to do
something like for more presentation
quality I'll wind up just messing around
a little bit till I find you know a set
of a figure size that looks good well I
mean scale is a sense like here I did 8
by 6 so obviously this axis is
physically longer than the vertical axis
and you know pandas laid out the numbers
correctly you can do things to control
the I'm just taking the default tick
marks and labels but you can do there's
lots of stuff you can do too if you want
like more granular tick marks you can
also do things like rotate the if you
have a lot of tick marks that need
labels you can rotate the text so it
doesn't all jump you know if you keep
getting into these deeper things you can
do a lot of stuff of you can do just
about anything you want
given enough code and pain is the answer
so so I'm just going to I'm just going
to create a new data so so why do you
use a line so a scatter plot is good
when you have a lot of data where each
you know they're not ordered in any way
right there's no order to these cars in
terms of like price and weight or price
and miles per gallon or anything like
that they're just they're just whatever
they are right it's just whatever order
I actually I think they're ordered by
manufacturer alphabetically but that has
nothing to do with the actual data
values right
so but but there are cases particularly
like time series plots
and some other cases where order matters
and so I'm going to create just a simple
data frame here and all I'm doing is
using the data frame method on a simple
dictionary that has an x and y column
and x is just a list of a hundred
numbers and y is the square though so
it's just it's just a going to define a
parabola and so you so the only thing
that's different here now is notice I
don't even have to say what what the
kind is with my plot method here on this
data frame because line plots turn out
to be a default when you hit four to
four for a two axis plot in in pandas so
and there you have it I mean it's not
it's not very beautiful but I just
wanted to show you guys the method for
doing line plots we're not going to do
much with that today but it is an
important plot type for certain types of
data so do be aware of it so bar plots
are a little tricky if you're used to
other plotting packages because there is
a bar plot method and you can see that
in this second set of code counts type
plot that bar but but it needs to be
based on counts not on you can't just
give us the column of from your original
data frame it there there is no that
method that bar plot method literally
just plots counts so what we got to do
is create counts and we're going to do
it we're going to look at the make make
is like the manufacturer and we're going
to use the value counts method okay
everybody with me on that so we wind up
with this series of one a single column
pandas data structure is called a series
because
it's not a data frame it doesn't have
there's not multiple columns so the
index of this series is just the
manufacturer and notice that it nicely
orders them this is just a the way
pandas works it nicely orders them from
the most frequent car to the
manufacturer with the most frequent cars
to the want manufacturer with the least
frequent and so now that we have counts
I'm going to apply the counts dot plot
dot bar method to but to that counts
series not to my original data frame ok
little tricky and notice I'm using yet a
different figure size here but all the
rest of this should be familiar by now
and well other than the fact I picked to
let me make my figure size smaller so
you guys can see it actually ok so now
we've got a nice ordered and and
something in terms of perception your
perception your colleagues perception
bosses and customers are whoever you're
going to present to it's always very
nice with a bar plot to order it either
this is descending order or it could be
a sending order but if you order it
people don't have to look and go okay I
see Toyota is the most common but is it
Nissan or Honda in this Honda more
common than Mitsubishi you know you can
hardly tell right and they're only
different actually I think they're those
three all have exactly the same number
of cars but if they were just in some
random order people would really have to
study your plot to understand it you
yourself would so which is one of those
things you want to avoid when you're
doing good data visualizations so order
order for the lesson is order order your
counts either ascending or descending
and it may matter you know depending on
what you're trying to do right so a
histogram any questions up to that point
then are we okay okay so a histogram is
like so a bar plot notice this is
discrete or categorical data a car is
either a Toyota you know it has a
manufacturer and it's one of the in this
particular data set it turns out to be
one of these names from this list and
but those are discrete values a car
can't be one point to Toyota or
something like that right but also
notice to somebody else's question it
pandas plotting does do this nice thing
when you get too many axes labels notice
how it new to change it kind of figured
out that oh I'm going to get a lot of if
I put those labels horizontally which is
the normal way to do it there's going to
be a lot of over printing so it turned
them vertically so that you can see them
better but you can do that you can force
that too so so a histogram we have a
continuous variable like engine size
engine size and these data are in cubic
inches and there's there's no
categorical you know car could have 144
cubic inch engine and could have 143 or
141 or you know whatever
so or 144 point six
that you know it is a numerical you know
it's a it's a continuous variable it's
not a categorical variable so therefore
we use histograms and histograms
you simply around some bins create
counts nicely pandas doesn't unlike bar
plots where they force you to compute
the counts yourself the histogram does
it all automatically
now one trick is if you just did Auto
prices dot plot dot hist a it would try
to make a histogram with all the numeric
variables plot it one on top in in some
funny way it
which probably isn't what you want I
mean maybe sometimes it is so you need
two subsets I'm subsetting that data
frame to just the column I'm interested
in right now engine size and so so
that's why that little extra bit there
with the square bracket subset operator
on column is is being used and all the
rest of this is the same you know where
we set up a figure we define an axis we
use that access for the titles and the
in the part new person once again you
know I should have gone through of sorry
I should have gone through and made
these all reasonable size you guys can
see so here's a histogram of engine size
and so in terms of when you look at this
there's a feature of this histogram that
really stands out what what is that
anybody but the nature of these autos
anybody because you've got really tiny
engines down here and some really
ginormous engines up here but what do
you see about that distribution
it's very skewed right auto
manufacturers at least in the sample
tended to have cars with pretty with on
the small end of engine size there was a
question could you do this with like
curb weight and engine size like well if
you want to play to factor or to yeah
that's where you could you could you
could play around with having like a I
don't know if this'll I don't know if I
can do this in real time but I think you
do something like you have to insert a
list here let's see
not just hmm I think that'll work
you need one more bracket on the right
oh oh right balloon there's oh yeah but
you get to see this is the problem you
get this clunky thing right where I was
wondering if you would like group them
together almost like a no no it tries to
plot them aside in the same set of axes
if I was to you know so this is so if
you want to look at engine size versus
curb weight for example that's probably
a better better option to use the
scatterplot this is a case like what I
was talking about right at the beginning
that you don't you know you need to
think about what are you trying to view
what of you know which when you reach
into your tool boxes of plot types which
plot type actually is going to display
with what you're hoping for and you know
you could do things you could you could
have two axes side by side or one above
another you know you could show the two
histograms if that somehow meant
something to you and your analysis but
if I was going to compare those I would
I would want to look at a scatter plot
that would be my first thought all right
so let's talk about box plots how many
people know what a what I'm even talking
about okay close to half the room good
so we just make some so so the idea of a
box plot the original ideas I think to
keep published lists originally in like
1960 or something so it's been around a
long time
and the idea was if you have a bunch of
I think this may actually go to the
question we just had of like comparing
distributions of two different you know
four different variables so so what if
you have something like engine size that
we were just looking at and then you
have
some categorical variable like fuel type
in this case I think these cars either
have gasoline or diesel engines so
there's only two fuel types and and so
so what we can do is we do we select
those two columns engine size and fuel
type and we use the boxplot method and
we say by equals fuel type so that's
like a group by so we're going to group
cars by fuel type and we're going to
display this box plot which I'll explain
in a minute and once again I got
ridiculously large
you know one you know it is probably
that the projection is lower resolution
oops I didn't I meant to do it the other
way okay so so what you can see is on
the left hand plot here we've got the
diesel engines the right-hand plot we
got the gas engines and then we have
engine size so so how do you compare
these things so the red lines are the
median value so you can see the median
value the median diesel engine is a bit
bigger than the median gasoline engine
then one quartile the data above the
median and one quartile of the data by
quartile I mean 1/4 of the values below
the below the median that's what defines
the box you can see the box is almost
overlap here then we go out another well
either till we run out of values or up
to one and a half quartiles and that's
called the whisker and then if we have
outliers beyond that we put these plus
signs so we can learn a little bit from
a plot like this it's it's not totally
definitive but it looks like maybe sort
of the bulk of diesel cars have maybe
slightly bigger engines you can see that
box is a little higher than this box
probably not that significant given the
overlap but you can also see the
gasoline cars have a much wider range of
engines from you know barely 50 cubic
inches way up to some pretty ginormous
engine that's like 300 and I don't know
whatever that would be 25 cubic inches
or something much bigger than any diesel
car because you see those plus signs for
the outliers and so that's a way to
compare and you could have multiple
we'll look at some examples where we
have more categories and you can quickly
compare so so now we're going to talk
about seaboard and Seaborn works a
little bit different from pandas
plotting
by the way is everybody with me up to
this this point now okay good alright so
assuming he has Seaborn successfully
installed which generally doesn't seem
to be a problem and I'm not quite sure
why all anaconda distributions don't
include it was there a question okay so
the simplest recipe that I've laid out
here for making a seaborne plot is to
import the package which always have to
do set a style for the plot grid and
that's kind of like setting up the axes
for the other plots we've seen although
it's not quite the same and you'll see
why that is I think in a while and then
you define and the plot type and and you
have to say which columns you want that
to apply to so in this case so we import
import Seabourn is SNS and so then I
have this method on SNS called set style
and I'm going to pick a style called
white grid that's just like the most
generic style it's just a white
background with a with a grid it you
know gridded axes so pretty pretty
pretty simple pretty generic so then I'm
going to use a method called KD plot for
kernel density and plot and I just going
to do that on engine size just on one
column now again if you had several you
know you if you had columns for engine
size for you know diesel and gas or
something you could do different things
here but let's just do this real simple
thing
oh and notice that sometimes you get
this weird deprecation warning so so
this looks a lot remember the histogram
we had of engine size so imagine that we
took a what's called a kernel estimator
which is like a Gaussian shaped curve
weighted curve and we ran that over
there and we found sort of a smooth fit
over that histogram instead of bidding
we tried to get a smooth fit over the
density of curves and there's one other
thing they do
it's a density it's a probability
density so the integral over this whole
curve has to add up to 1 which is you
know one of the axioms of probability
right so but you can see the in this
case I don't think we're learning a
whole lot more we're seeing that as we
discovered before manufacturers have a
tendency to build cars with much with
smaller engines it's only a few sort of
outlier cars that have these really
large engines okay now notice also what
went away here because I didn't specify
I did this in a real simple way what's
what's missing yeah my axis labels and
my my title and all that because I
didn't do anything about it so let's
okay so you can probably guess that's
what we're going to do next so again we
can define it define a set of AXI the
fine a figure define a set of axes and
when we say that we're going to do this
KD plot method we say ax equals x and
then we can just as we did with like the
pandas plots and you can do this with
mat plot live plots so that's why it's
important to kind of understand all this
stuff is coming up from math plot libe
this whole business of the set underbar
title set underbar
our xlabel etc is all just matplotlib
stuff that can be superimposed on
another any other some of these other
plots and so now I've kind of decorated
this plot with proper access labels and
a title okay
so so before we get off kernel density
estimation plot I just point out that
there's another thing you can do which i
think is actually sometimes really cool
and this is partly someone pointed out
that we had a lot of over plotting when
we looked at engine size versus price
and this was partly a way to get around
that oh yes what was the question
that's a deprecation warning some
versions you get that it actually ran it
down once and they said oh it's a bug so
after reading like pages and pages of
discussion so that's why I made a note
earlier on to just ignore that if you
get it I don't know is anybody else
besides me getting it no a few people ok
so it depends what version of manic on
they've got I guess or which version the
Seabourn you got I'm not sure where it's
I think it's actually coming from math
plotline not even from Seaborn
but feel free to ignore it and that's
why it's a warning it's not an error
message it's a warning and it also turns
out to be an incorrect warning because
it's not actually a problem so okay so
2d plots to to eat so it's the same KDE
plot but now I just give it a list so I
have square bracket than square brick
you know then a list with another square
bracket so I just have a list of so I've
got two columns engine size and price oh
and I'm also going to someone asked
about colors so the sea map is like a
like a color
I'm going to pick from and and you'll
see why that is and if you look in the
in the Seaborn documentation or the
tutorials somewhere down here there's a
whole menu
yeah color palettes there's a whole yeah
a lot of stuff about color palettes they
they do a really nice job of color
palettes with Seaborn there's a lot of
flexibility a lot of cool stuff you can
do
they've also thought about like that a
lot of a big percentage of people are
red-green color blind so they try to
steer away from red-green palettes and
stuff like that so it's whoever did this
really knew what they were doing yes in
the last tutorial when they were doing
the plotting it was a method of the data
frame itself what's the difference
between doing it this way versus the
other way well okay so we're not using
pan this is now Seabourn so it's a
completely different thing but you could
also do some way back to the pandas
plotting let's see what was our last
like this one I think I could do cow
counts dot plot and then let's see well
we can try it it should be let's see I
think like kind equals and then I think
bar has to be in quotes and then I need
a comma alright
oh and get rid of that I think that will
come up with the same plot yeah see it's
the answer is it doesn't matter it's a
style thing I you can do it you can
explain Quentin did his pandas tutorial
he was using a style like this counts
dot plot and then he would say kind
equals whereas I'm doing counts plot dot
plot method like this
I don't know do you like do you like
arguments to your methods or the list of
methods in your code I it they as far as
I can tell they're interchangeable I've
never noticed a difference but it's a
good observation of the detail okay so
let's get back to yeah here we are so so
so I was explaining so I've got this
list of two columns here that's so I'm
subsetting my data for my auto prices
data frame to just those two columns and
I've set this color palette so let's let
that go and there you go there's other
things in that I'm sorry you know I'm I
tested this on my standalone display
which obviously has more resolution than
the projector so alright so now you can
see it so you can see that there is in
fact you know this is like a contour map
like a topo map or something and you can
see what that color palette is doing it
starts out the lowest rungs are close to
black and the lightest runs there's such
a dark blue they almost look black and
then the top rung is this really light
light blue up here right in and so when
we talked about over plotting and that
there were a lot of data points so let's
go back to the scatter plot you'll see
what I mean
way back sorry so see in some of these
areas here there's just so many dots you
can't really tell how many are on top
one on top of each other and we call
that over plotting and this is only you
know we only have as we saw 195 cars in
this sample but imagine you were doing
this on customers for an e-commerce site
where you might have millions or
something this over plotting becomes an
overwhelming issue and so you need other
methods to deal with it so one of them
is this Colonel Vincent the studio --all
density estimation plot like this
another which I don't think we go into
is is called a hex bin plot hex bin
plots well if you look at my github
you'll see actually I think I just have
a link to it but some work Ryan happen
and I did where we were plotting making
scatter plots of every home sale in the
United States for the last 20 years or
something like that was a fairly big
data set not giant you know not big data
big but big and we use these hex bin
plots and it gave a similar effect
whereas if we had done scatter plots we
just would have had blobs it would have
been so many dots one on top of the
other it just would have been an you
know an uninterpretable blob so when
you're making plots if you if you wind
up with blobs think about other methods
like this 2d kernel density estimation
or hex bin plots so is it clear to
everybody why this is giving us what
it's giving us and what do you conclude
from looking at something like this oops
so the question
airline life
you mean this plot oh yeah right because
we're doing engine size here it gives a
legend but in this case I've given it to
I've given it two columns that we're
sort of contouring over so it's price on
the vertical engine size on the
horizontal you don't really need a
legend Oh a 3d plot yeah you can do that
in matte flat libe I don't think there's
any 3d plotting and Seabourn
effect I'm pretty sure there isn't so so
the answer is you can do it with enough
work with matplotlib primitives in fact
I think in those the resources I gave
you if you click through that look at
some of those tutorials there's actually
some examples of that but it's a lot of
code so be more if you really need to do
it do it I also make the comment one of
the I'm not keen on 3d plots because
they they're so dependent this is
something cleveland looked at and some
other people i think i think i think to
fee even talks about this that it
depends on if you have a 3d surface
imagine you have to have an eye point of
perspective and how people will view how
peaky and rough your surfaces depends on
you know how its oriented and so it can
be very tricky in fact you know pipe
you'll notice I don't I mean there's a
number of types of plots I don't use I
don't use 3d plots generally I don't use
pike pie charts because I think I think
it was Tookie said they're an excellent
tool for a few skating almost any any
point you're trying to make even though
if you look at like infographics and
news sites and stuff they're very
popular but but if you think about it I
have some examples for another class I
teach which is longer and we look at
some having to do with elections in
various countries
there's a lot of political parties I
mean it looks like some sort of
psychedelic pattern you cannot tell who
which party has what percentage of the
vote in the parliament or something like
that it was just it's just useless so so
anyway what but what do you guys when
you look at this plot it's it's it's
actually telling us something pretty
interesting I mean assuming you're that
interested in the price of cars but what
is it anyway yeah well I wouldn't say
they're the same so I don't think that's
quite true because the units are quite
different for one thing but they do they
do tend to be ellipse I mean there is a
high covariance right they get down to
be elliptical you know so anything with
ellipses sort of indicates you know
where they elongated ellipse on these
contours but there was just something
even more obvious than that
yeah so hundred well cutting its cubic
inches but yeah there are lots of cheap
cars with hundred cubic inches
roughly engines on the market in 1985 so
because it's there's a clear peak and
there's only one peak in this sir I
think this question way in the back okay
yeah
yeah so you'll get yeah so the question
is if we did this with city MPG you get
to because you actually get a little
more complicated so first off there's
obviously some outlier cars that that oh
well this is city miles per gallon I
didn't change the label apologies anyway
so there's some pretty low fuel
efficiency expensive cars there seems to
be a cluster of those those actually I
can spill the beans those are luxury
cars so they're not built for fuel
efficiency up in that corner and then
you see yeah there's two modes of this
where manufacturers either want these
really cheap high fuel efficiency cars
or kind of mid I imagine they're sort of
midsize cars or something like that so
yeah so you can you know it this is a
good point though that you know you want
to look at lots I mentioned this when we
started you always want to look at lots
of views of your data and this is a you
know there's only 20 20 columns or
something that we're working with in
this data set but you can see even with
just 20 columns there's a fair amount of
complexity here that if you were trying
to really understand this and maybe you
were trying to build a machine learning
model to predict the price of cars based
on certain attributes or something like
that maybe for your competitors if you
work for a car company or something you
know you you would really have to work
quite a bit to fully understand this and
be able to create a deep understanding
of what what these data are telling you
so another interesting plot is the
violin plot so it's very similar to the
box so it kind of combines the best of
box plot and density plots and so kind
of like the box plot we have an X which
is a categorical variable and it should
always be a categorical variable
fuel-type and then we have a Y which is
a continuous variable so we'll just use
engine size but we could use price we
could do you know you could use lots of
different columns and like I say in
practice if we were really doing this
exploration as a real project we'd be
doing probably hundreds or thousands of
plots till we figured it out but let's
just do this one okay and so you can see
it looks like you can imagine that
kernel density estimation plot we looked
at for engine size before where we just
looked at all cars so you can imagine so
it's got the same thing on the left and
on the right it's just symmetric so you
can look at either side and it just
shows you there is a distinct peak in
the gasoline cars and kind of the diesel
cars their engine size is sort of more
uniformly distributed right and you can
actually see they've done a little box
plot II kind of thing in here the dot
the white dot is is the median and you
can see the upper the upper enter the
upper inner quartile the lower inner
quartile you know etc and you can also
see as we saw before with the box plots
there's a lot of outliers in gasoline
cars is apparently a lot of gasoline
cars with really big engines okay so
everything we've done up till now
everybody okay up till now okay so so
let's so we're going to now switch gears
we're about halfway through our time or
a little more and we're going to start
looking at ways to extend beyond two
dimensions everything we've done has
been one or two dimension one
dimensional plots like histograms and
the 1d kernel density estimation 2d
plots like the scatter plots and the
contour plots and things like that so
let's start looking at aesthetics and so
the first is so we're going to look at
color transparency size marker shape and
some plot specific aesthetics
and so color color is a very tricky
aesthetic it seems very simple like oh I
can just color but but there's a lot of
probs I already mentioned the issue that
a lot of people are red-green especially
men for some reason our red-green color
blind so when you think of what palette
you're going to use four colors consider
those kinds of things
Seabourn actually does a pretty good job
of suggest the palettes that are kind of
the standard palettes try to avoid ones
that are hard for colorblind people but
there's a method in Seabourn called and
also don't pick too many colors I've
seen plots I just saw one the other day
where as we were working on and someone
had done like 20 colors and you couldn't
tell the difference between all these
shades of red and all these shades of
green and we were going back and forth
and back and forth between the legend
and the and the dots and the you know it
was very dependent on every everybody
saw something different you know so so
don't go crazy with any actually that's
true many of these aesthetics you can
show a certain number of other
dimensions but you can't show huge
numbers of values so this LM plot it
just means linear model plot but I'm
actually going to set rig fit to false
because I don't want to you get
regression lines is what happens on the
plot which can be really useful but in
this case I don't want to confound what
we're really looking at which is we're
going to set the hue as fuel-type and
I'm going to use this set to palette
okay
so right away
so you can see what happened here fuel
type sir gas or diesel and you can see
the the red dots are the diesel and the
kind of greenish dots okay I guess they
did pick red green in this case but or
at least I did the blue I guess they're
more like blue green but anyway so so
you can see something now interesting
about this price versus miles per gallon
which which is what what does that tell
you about gasoline versus diesel cars
anybody yeah you get more mileage for
your for the amount of money you spend
on your car if you buy a diesel car
which I mean everybody probably knows
that but this demo you can see that in
almost every case the diesel cars are to
the right of the gasoline cars at almost
every price level and remember before we
saw this clump of kind of very high cost
low efficiency cars those are these
luxury cars if you don't believe me you
can you can make a plot and just do like
you know Mercedes and Porsche and Jaguar
and a few makes in a select and you'll
see that's true so or you so it gets a
little complicated I don't want to spend
the we just going to have the time to go
through this but I wanted to guys to see
you can get a lot more control and you
can use the pandas plotting methods in
this case I'm going to create but I just
want to give you the general recipe so
what I did is again I define a figure we
make it smaller see guys so it doesn't
spill out again I set some axes and I
basically subset my data frame for gas
so I've created two data frames here for
gas and diesel and if I had four
categories I'd have to do four
data frames and then I apply and I also
make sure that there's something in that
data frame so the shape the first shape
shape is the the number of rows and the
number of columns in the data frame so
shape zero is the number of rows so if
the number of rows is greater than zero
I'll go ahead and plot it because I
don't want to error out if I have to in
this function if I happen to have it but
that's a this kind of a technical detail
so I'm going to plot both of these and
you can also do this as a list I mean
it's there's probably more elegant ways
to do this but I thought this was more
straight and so I've got kind equals
scatter I guess to someone's question
that was before Y so in this case I'm
not doing the plot method as a dot and
doing it as a kind and I'm going to give
those colors dark blue and those red and
everything else is oh and then I'm doing
some I'm creating some legends here so I
just do that and I have essentially the
same plot you just saw using Seabourn a
lot more code but I just wanted to show
you guys for future if you you can get a
lot more control this way at the expense
of a lot more code so let's look at
transparency so we looked at over
plotting in one method which was the 2d
scatter plots but so now now we get to
something where you have to do what the
recipe I just showed you because I can
set something called alpha and by the
way alpha is the same in Seabourn it's
the same in math lot live it's the same
in pandas so alpha is a transparency
value so alpha of zero is completely
transparent you wouldn't see the points
at all alpha of one is what we've been
working with it's perfectly opaque you
can't see through it at all
so we're going to try point three
and you see these signal points up here
look pretty pretty fuzzy now and you can
start to get some better idea of down
here where there's over plotting where
there's really a lot of points or maybe
just one or two on top of each other
okay so transparency is pretty useful so
so here's a little code exercise for you
yeah we have time for that so copy go
ahead and do copy-paste and do this kind
of do the same thing for engine size and
curb weight so this is like price and
and city miles per gallon but go ahead
and create a similar plot for engine
size and curb weight you can you can try
the pandas or you can I'm gonna I think
I'm going to try it with Seaborn see if
I can get it to work
so it would be
Oh for those of you new to notebooks if
you need a new just go insert cell below
and you get a cell for your code
what did I say Injuns are
that's the problem doesn't attitude okay
so you see that's why okay so see born
doesn't know about alpha there's a way
too much
huh keep it didn't like it give me the
Alpha Oh
let's turn
so that's the argument oh yeah okay I'm
remembering this now yeah but it's I'm
trying to remember is it is it an
argument - LM plot or something else you
apply where do you have to do another
call on SNS with a different method
yeah I think it seems like something you
ought to be able to do but
[Laughter]
yes hahaha
okay
just guess
ah
all right
so I kind of did it the hard way
although it sounds like there's a better
way to do it with with Seaborn but you
get the basic idea but it's just a
different view of the data engine size
and curb weight not too surprisingly
pretty highly correlated and generally
diesel engines
if you turn X you can flip the axis
around you'd see that cars tend to have
somewhat smaller engine size per weight
if they're diesels okay so the last
thing we've got here is marker size and
marker size is is M is again one of
these tricky things that you don't want
to get too carried away but you can use
it on a continuous variable and so this
is the same code we've been working with
and I'm just going to and what I've done
is S is for the size attribute you see
and it's and I did point five just to
get a scaling of Auto prices of engine
size so now we're going to so well let
me make this plot and then you'll see
what's what's interesting about it
so you see the size of the dots now
varies with the engine size you see
we've got gas and diesel cars we've got
price and cities miles to gallon so how
many dimensions so I advertised that we
were going to look at multiple
dimensions using using these aesthetics
so how many dimensions are we actually
plotting here now from our
multi-dimensional data set I think
somebody's saying four yeah that's right
so we've got type of engine fuel we've
got engine size we've got price we've
got cities miles to the gallon but can
you guys see that there's kind of a
little bit of a problem it's a little
hard to say I mean these dots aren't
that different in size like from these
these luxury cars with the really big
engines and clearly you can see for some
of these economy cars they're smaller
but it's not that distinct right so one
trick is to to go with engine size scoop
squared so I've got auto price and so I
just multiply the two columns together
here you could create a new column in
the data frame too and you can see that
don't you think that makes well let me
let me rescale that for you
so I think I mean that to me to my eye
and probably to yours doesn't that look
a lot different that you can see these
cars with these really big engines over
here and a few down here and really
small engines in some of these other
areas so so keep that in mind to the
differences this is now engine size is
now proportional to the area of the of
the shape and you can change shapes to
we'll talk about that in a sec and as
opposed to the linear dimension of the
shape so this is work people like
Cleveland and others have done that the
human eye is more sensitive to the area
of the shape you're looking at than the
linear dimension and so finally we are
going to use marker shape so so I know
it's getting kind of confused so we've
got size we've got color
we've got alpha and then we're going to
do marker equals m'kay so I've got this
list of zeros and pluses and a list of
colors
and you can see turbo cars are dots are
and standard or and stand I'm sorry yeah
and standard cars or crosses so if it's
a turbo with the circle if it's a
standard car so yeah once again so I did
not think to I didn't think about how
how different the resolution would be on
the screen so there you go
so how many dimensions are we now
projecting on to this two-dimensional
surface
anybody just lost five
yeah five is right because we've got
whether it's standard or turbo we've got
whether it's gas or diesel we've got the
engine size we've got the price and
we've got the fuel efficiency so five
dimensions on a two-dimensional so we're
using three different plot aesthetics
here which at least the way I did it
here is a little bit quite a bit of code
but that's not so important I'm going to
skip a little bit of this yeah it could
be I should have used triangles or
something yeah so his question is the
plus shapes maybe don't look as weighty
is the equivalent dots yeah maybe to
some people sighs so you could use
triangles or squares or something like
that there's there's ways to do yeah
that that might have been a better
choice perhaps something that you see an
area so let me just go here and do so
plot specific aesthetics are lots of
things like here I'm just going to do
this real quick with histograms so I've
done is change the number of bins so
we're back to pandas plotting here so in
one case I just took the default in one
case I said bins equals for you so I
think the default is ten and you can see
they're pretty chunky bins right but it
looks but the histogram looks kind of
smooth and easy to interpret what's the
problem with 40
let me see more detail but but does that
really tell you more what do we think
the problem is there
it's just looking at noise is just you
know it's just it doesn't mean that much
that it's just jumping from one little
bin to the next by so much so obviously
I've picked too many bins so when you're
creating things like histograms density
the density plot you can set up what's
called the kernel with think about and
try different things to find something
that suits your data now if we had you
know ten thousand values instead of 195
maybe even smaller bin widths would
start to make sense for a histogram but
we only have 195 data points so we can't
push the push it too much so a cool
thing you can do we already looked at
color with Seabourn with some of those
other plots but here I'm doing hue is
aspiration I'm doing this for the violin
plot so it's the same violin plot we
looked at before with fuel type so
you've got you know so again we just set
set our grid you know we we apply the
violin plot method fuel type price
aspiration so the new thing is this
aspiration and when split equals true so
you'll see what that does in a minute so
what it means is now we get remember
before we had just the two sides of the
violin plot we're just mirror images of
each other they weren't different at all
but now we can see whether they're
standard or turbo on either side and it
shows that in a nice different color so
this gives us a way so we've al got how
many dimensions on this plot three yeah
three so we've got whether it's gas or
diesel
we've got whether it's standard or turbo
and we've got the price and you can do
the same thing for engine size etc or
with box plots let's do something a
little different so body style there's a
lot more body styles
yeah sorry I can't
so in the violent large after in this
plot yes there's a median and and oh the
median is gained for the whole group
it's not it's it's not giving you like
two medians and two you have to look at
the density plots on the left and the
right to get the differences yes so you
could create other subsets or other
variables too so I we don't need to go
through this but you can see if you buy
because there's five body styles you can
see you get quite different box plots
for gas and diesel depending on whether
it's like a I think one of these is a
convertible etc so I just wanted to show
you that okay so yeah okay so we've got
half an hour so I think we've got enough
time to do a little exercise here so and
so so we just looked at that violin plot
so try it with Drive wheels so just make
the violin plot a price so it's priced
by aspiration but make the hew drive
wheels and you'll see it'll be different
there's three types of Drive wheels I
just want to show you just see so it's
pretty quick to do that just do some cut
and paste
I think that's right what's the variable
a I get it all the way back out
I have wheels
oh I'm sorry yeah it's not the Huey all
right I should have kept the hue the
same it's the its this should be Drive
wheels and the X so you can do it it's
what you get and this one then should be
fuel type
okay right okay yeah that's what I
wanted to show
so yeah and the point is like as the
error message is the person pointed out
the error message said you can only have
two to a two-level categorical variable
to do this color split so obviously I
could use gas and diesel or fuel type or
I could use aspiration but this
interesting thing with four-wheel drive
vehicles what do you see yeah there's no
there's no diesel four-wheel drive
vehicles in these data so but you know
and you can see that every one of these
for front-wheel drive vehicles you can
see that they tend to be the cheap cars
regardless of whether they're gas or
diesel they're all clumped down there at
the cheap end rear-wheel drive cars have
this big range and in four-wheel drive
cars for some reason or down there so
okay so I promise we're going to look at
multiple axes types and so let's spend
the rest of our time on that so this so
everything we've done has just had one x
axis one y axis up till now so now we're
going to look at multi axis plots and
there's a couple ways to to skin that
cat and this is a scatter plot matrix
it's called a joint plot in Seabourn and
we're going to do engine size by price
and
so a joint plot is just a scatter plot
as you see and then it gives you the
histogram of what what we would call the
marginal densities along this edge so
that's why it's called a split plot but
you see we we've added these extra x
axes which are the accounts or the
densities on the edges so that's just a
simple example of now a plot that you
know tells us something new but is quite
you know but you can't create a plot
like that with just one pair of axes
right so another more complicated plot
is a pairwise scatter plot and Seabourn
has this thing called pair plot these
things I probably see them before
they've been around for a long time at
least 30 years we're going to do I'm
going to define the numeric columns to
be these this you can do categorical
columns but I'm just going to stick with
numeric columns we're going to use fuel
type as Hugh and we're going to use that
same palette and on the diagonal I'm
going to put kernel density plots and
I've set a and we're going to do KDE
plots those 2d kernel density estimation
plots on the upper diagonal so you'll
see this this might take a little while
to compute here
in a warning message which choosing to
ignore for now okay so there's a lot
going on here as you can see so here
we've got so the way you read this is
you've got lengths curb weight engine
size horsepower city miles per gallon
price then you've got exactly the same
variable names on this axis so so you've
got price by length down in this corner
here you've got price by curb weight but
if you want to look at curb weight by
price you let's see curve would see so
you can see the kernel density plot of
let's see curb weight by price will be
this one here so you can see there's
sort of two peaks in that you can see
for gas and diesel cars because that's
what we used as a as the hue you can see
the histogram or the kernel density
plots for each of those so so now so now
how many how many dimensions do we have
on our plot
count them up nine because we got eight
eight numeric columns plus fuel type as
a categorical so we got nine all right
so someone asked this question about
multiple plot axes and so the way we
kind of snuck into this once before but
so I can so here I've got my figure and
my axis let's typical Python stuff right
with the comma because I this function
is going to return this method is going
to return two things a figure and an
axis they do plot that subplots two by
two so that means I'm doing a two by two
array of subplots
and this is like way too big a figure
size and one percent I'm going to do
eight by eight and then so I'm just
going to say so so I've got an X so this
little function so I can say what my X
column my Y column are and we're just
going to do histograms so you can see I
subset with some kind of gnarly notation
here and then plot dot hist so I'm
actually using matplotlib x' plot method
histogram method here so I've gone all
the way down to the base math plot live
for now good I mean I could have used
paint I could have created data frames
here and use pandas or something like
that or Seabourn but it was just easier
well at least in my view is easier to
just create two lists called X calls and
white calls and iterate over over them
or enumerate over them
but the important thing is then you see
I do in fact have it well I've got all
sorts of over plotting here so I'd have
to work on this more right to get these
separated a little bit in all this but I
think you get the idea that the key
things I've done here is I've defined a
figure in a set of axes that's a 2 by 2
array of axes you guys all see that
that's like the important thing to
notice here and and you can see I'm
having problems I've got some over plot
printing and I can't really read my axis
and my axis labels are a little funny
and I'd have to go back if I wanted to
compare these histograms they'd have to
go back and create code to make sure
that the the the x axis lengths were
exactly the same on each of these but
fortunately there's an easier way to do
this which is called facet plotting and
so this if you run into this it can be
called conditioned plotting which i
think is what cleveland originally
called it it can be called the method of
small multiples which is what toothed d
originally called it it can be called
facet nowadays most people call it facet
plotting it's sometimes called grouped
plotting so it's but think about it as a
group by operation where you divide your
data and then plot it on multiple axes
ok and the basic idea is remember we
just created a standard grid before with
Seabourn but now we're going to use this
facet grid method and I'm going to say
columns equals drive wheels so I'm going
to do a group by drive wheels and so
whatever I plot here and I use this map
method I'm going to use a rake plot of
engine size and price and I'm not going
to show that regression line so is that
clear with what's going on there that
we're creating a grid which only has
columns so it's a one row buy however
columns of drive wheels which will be
three and then and then I'm plotting
engine size and price okay so so there
you have it and you notice some
interesting things first off the axes
facet grid methods make the axes exactly
all the same length so I can compare one
plot to the other to the other so that's
really nice it also figures out that I
don't really need another set of axes
labels here and here I can just use
those and so so it just saves me a lot
of time and it does the group by map you
know the group by I don't have to I had
that gnarly stuff in the code here where
I was effectively doing I could you know
a grouping or a sub setting so and you
can do like let's try one with Drive
wheels by body style so we go now we're
doing columns and rows okay so our grid
now is going to have two dimensions this
is the one dimensional grid this next
set of code it's the same engine size by
price but we're going to do it we're
going to create subplots by drive wheels
and body style all right and you can see
there's three types of Drive wheels and
there's actually five types of body
steps so it's a lot of different plots
there's a couple things you can see like
like there's no four-wheel drive
hardtops you see there's there's no dots
there right there's only one there's
only one and you see how I'm reading
these it's body style equals hardtop
drive wheels equals front wheel drive
there's only one so most hard tops
whatever I'm not even sure what a
hardtop is but whatever they are they're
mostly rear-wheel drive cars and you see
start to see
you know some price relationships for
these different subsets so this is a
very limited data set as I keep saying
it's only 195 points but if you had
thousands of points and you wanted to
explore high dimensional projections of
them this gives you a really powerful
way to do it this this facet gridding
method and you can add aesthetics so
like let's do hue of fuel type so this
is basically I'm just making the same
plot you just saw with fuel type and you
don't see so again you don't see many I
think the diesel cars are the red dot so
you don't see any like there are no
convertibles with diesel engines so you
don't see any red dot in fact there's no
four-wheel drive convertibles so so
there's no dots there at all and then
but here you start to see sedans with
front-wheel drive and they're kind of
tightly clustered compared to say sedans
with rear-wheel drive which have a wide
range of prices and in engine sizes so
so it's not the best example of using
this kind of scatter plot but so one
last exercise if you guys want to hang
on for a bit which you have time please
by the schedule so go ahead and do this
but change one of the axes to city miles
per gallon instead of engine size
because remember we started with that so
you can pretty much cut and paste and do
a few changes here
but we'll keep all the other the
faceting variables and the color the hue
is fuel-type etc so it's really a pretty
minimal change
and you mister
so everybody get it and it's just a very
simple change here we just had to change
change this to city miles per gallon and
you can see yes they do you see some
interesting stuff like again sedans with
rear wheel drives have a big range of
price and a big range of fuel efficiency
but there are no highly fuel-efficient
sedans right there they just sort of in
there kind of in the mid-range rear
front wheel drive sedans have better
mileage and you keep going down here
let's see where the hatchbacks
oh yeah hatchbacks so you can see the
all the really really fuel-efficient
cars or hatchbacks so even though we
don't have an ideal data set to use this
kind of gridding method here you I hope
you guys can see that what the value is
in terms of dividing data into small
pieces small chunks and being able to
compare it on exactly the same axes side
by side by side there's also a ways if
you want it to free one axis and not the
other you can set that there's all kinds
of specialized things you can do with
this and you have to think about as
you're visualizing a data set on what to
do so in summary I hope I've given you a
bunch of tools bag of tools and and also
pointed out some places you can go for
the tutorials and what to learn more
things and given you know so you know
how to do this with Python and also
looked at kind of the process of how you
explore data and why you explore data
and stuff you can learn from exploring
data when you have complex relationships
and you really want to understand it
before you you know waste a lot of time
doing some complicated analysis where
you don't really understand what you
know what the simple relationships might
be between your variables
so that's so are there any questions or
anybody Oh got a couple back there yep
so the question is can you make these
graphs interactive not with the packages
we've been looking at you can do some
animation like Matt plot life has an
animation system that's actually kind of
cool so you could like step through a
bunch of categorical variables or
something so if a student have time to
go into that if you want truly
interactive Python graphics I suggest
you look at the bouquet package which is
a whole we could do another two hours
just on that it's its own world but it
but it's and it's it's the other nice
thing about is it's it's directly usable
in websites so so it actually has a
couple of really cool things about it
but like I said it's a whole other thing
oh yeah there's lots of stuff on bouquet
I think there might even be a bouquet
book or to it yeah yeah yeah right
someone's there's a talk on Friday yes
for sure but not a tutorial in this
conference although it'd be nice there
was a way in the May
yeah yeah that's a good suggestion to
the I pi widgets if you want to do
simple simple interactive stuff those
work pretty close are pretty nice too
for in there specifically for Jupiter so
if you're doing it in Jupiter than the
Lynn you that might be what you need
there was a question there yeah hi so
I'm relatively new to this visualization
with Python and let's say I have an idea
for a plot I want to make how do I
decide where to look for how to learn
how to do that Matt plot live Seabourn
pandas how do I decide yeah I know so
the question is given all these
different packages and we just breezed
through like the surface of three of
them how do you decide I you know I
don't think I don't think there's like a
best answer to your question my general
rule of thumb is this I look at see born
first usually because it's it is more
abstract you know they abstract a lot
more things as you saw we didn't write
nearly as much code to get fairly
complex plots out of it second might be
pandas plotting especially if your data
and pandas dataframe and then I kind of
you only use matplotlib if I have to
really get into some detail and I hope
that some helpful guidelines but it's
not you know that there isn't like a
absolute best answer it really depends
on what you're trying to do
unfortunately any other questions or
just Punk thanks Steven yeah thank you
[Applause]